bang-bang what's up how are you guys
this morning lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get a lunch money
right I'm here with the beautiful Clint
Amer Nova who kind of has the uniform on
or the black t-shirt but now I think
that what is this bodybuilding season
sneaker on us just show us the guns it
is what the guns don't bring those
deadly weapons on it on the show all
right let's go play what's going on with
the unemployment situation the economic
pain continues another 3.8 four million
US weekly jobless claims so these are
our first time filers of unemployment
3.8 million brings us over 30 million
over the last six weeks there's two ways
look at it one is the number each week
is going down from that high of you know
whatever it was six point six million
but at the same time we're like
desensitized to the data right like we
forget that 3.8 million sounds like oh
look it's getting better right but 3.8
million if that had happened in February
that would have been a 50% increase in
total national unemployment not a single
week right so it's just again look we
don't want to beat a dead horse here but
we got to get people back to work we got
to get the economy turned back on yeah
do it safely but I think that that is if
it's obvious that the unemployment
numbers are not going to get better any
time until we reopen cities so so this
is interesting so unemployment insurance
claims the last six weeks thirty point
three million the number of jobs created
since the Great Recession in 2008-2009
is twenty two point four million so all
that job creation has been wiped out
yeah that doesn't surprise me
that's right I mean think about it it's
much easier to fall off the cliff and
then you got to think of it like a
mountain really it takes hours and hours
and hours to climb to a mountain if you
just jump off right you fall to ground
real fast say the same thing here is
just it's easier for a big economic fall
and then it'll take us years to build
back these jobs but ok so the number of
jobs that were lost
during the Great Recession was only only
but 8.7 million compared to 30 million
we we literally are all sitting at home
the government said we have guns and men
and women in uniform and if you don't go
home and shut down your business we're
gonna come arrest you we're gonna find
you we're gonna do all these things well
guess what ends up happening you get
everyone goes home and they have to fire
people 30 million Americans that's crazy
that's absurd
one in five people in the labor force or
without job right now
one in five if you go on average and you
talk to four friends you were one of
them lost their job yeah I told you I
know five people five people yeah sad I
know all right what's going on with Elon
Musk Elon went off yesterday
so Ellen's just being Elon this is
literally not surprising to me
whatsoever but in the Tesla earnings
call he kind of popped off and said that
orders to stay home are fascist and he
used some inappropriate language
do you disagree with him the money
printer is going but do you disagree so
here's the thing let me preface this by
saying I actually like Elon and think
he's done a lot to kind of push humanity
an innovation forward if you read his
biography by Ashley Vance very
fascinating person um
I think that there's a time and a place
for things I don't think that on a Tesla
earning scholarship the earnings call is
actually good for Tesla like they had
great numbers I'm not sure that's the
right forum to express your opinion
about forcible imprisonment in fascism
okay but you didn't answer the question
do you agree with them I agree with the
spirit okay so basically what he said is
he says listen the the quotes are are
pretty aggressive he basically says you
can't require people to stay home you
can't literally say if you do if you
leave your home we're going to arrest
you his point is it's fascist it's not
democratic that is not what freedom is
about and at the same time when he
describes on what I actually think was
was left out of a lot of the news
coverage of this is he's sticking up for
small businesses right when he basically
said at one point
look Tesla can weather this but most
small businesses can't and so you want
to stay home stay home right there
should be no penalty against that but
what you shouldn't be able to do is tell
me what you have to stay yes okay so
it's your show now I mean you're
basically the the host and everything so
just go ahead whatever you want what the
alternatives have been is this what he's
suggesting is that's what you're
suggesting that instead of telling
people you must think home the
government should have said if you want
to stay home you should I don't think
anybody would have listened okay so my
point all along has been when you tell
people you have to do it or there is a
penalty it's a violation of their
constitutional rights if you look at
somewhere like Sweden there's something
called herd immunity right in Sweden mom
Sweden didn't tell people you have to
stay home there's no shelter in place or
what they instead said was wash your
hands stay socially distant right do all
these things and they actually have
really really good health data now
there's something to be said about the
relationship that the Swedish government
has with their population there's a lot
more collaboration they listen more all
this kind of stuff part of the thing is
that the United States everyone even now
to stay at home order so people are in
Central Park right so they're not just
gonna listen but I do believe that the
solution here is not black and white
shut the economy or dump or overwhelm
the healthcare system don't instead is
this middle ground and all I keep going
back to is like you should shelter the
old the sick and those with pre-existing
conditions you should legally protect
the people who don't want to go to work
they're scared or they're afraid they're
gonna get sick you should open the
economy and say if you're under a
certain age you voluntarily can go back
and you should still impose things like
wear a mask wash your hands stay
socially distant like all of these
measures and so it's kind of this not a
black-and-white solution it's in the
gray area and you try to address both
problems at the same time that's hard
and Sweden is widely different from the
United States but do you think that in a
place like New York City people would
have been like oh okay I'll be social it
does say well they're doing it right now
because they're forced to but there's
nothing that is forcing you right now to
be socially distant they're forcing you
to spend to not go to work they
force the businesses to be shut but
there's nobody on the street sitting
there saying I'm gonna find you or
arrest you if you're standing within
social pressure but the social pressure
comes from the political pressure of
course but that's something you can do
that without forcing the businesses to
be closed like here's here's my example
so there's many small businesses that
are around us here in New York right and
Duane Reade and CBS are open they're
considered essential businesses and the
whole idea is that you can go into the
store you can stay six feet away from
people you can buy a good and you can
leave yeah
and that's okay that's that that falls
within but what about the stores that
sell other things why can't I go in that
store stay six feet apart from everybody
by the hood at least well just any store
right the liquor stores open I can go
and stay six feet away buy liquor and
leave why can't I do that in any store
that sells any good it's the same
mechanism the difference is and that's
why people are getting upset that's why
Ilan said look these small businesses
are suffering but you're not shutting
down every business but you can
implement the same measures and then
again if you're scared of being sick or
getting sick don't go into work don't go
outside and let's legally protect you
let's make sure that if you don't go
back to work because you're worried you
can't get hired you can't get you know
you're paid off except us it's
definitely time I actually think that
he's gonna catch a lot of flack for this
but his general sentiment is right he
used very very strong language like
fascism I think at one point he said
like imprisonment yeah like that like
that stuff is gonna make it much more
salacious being SAT were there for you
and the headlines and people are gonna
write about yes salacious is a bigger
essay giggling what's going with
American Airlines baby that's all the
best they're the best AAA forever are
you allowed to bring those guns on the
plane you know why cuz Gerald [ __ ]
Baskin alright what's going on what's
going on with American Airlines 2.2
billion in the first quarter is
coronavirus roiled air travel so
revenues down 20%
most airlines have seen 95 percent
decrease in bookings they lost two point
two billion dollars in q1 remember a lot
of that is back loaded meaning that
across the quarter in January they still
have pretty good numbers February got a
little worse March got a little worse
and then really the last two weeks like
everything's off a cliff but the big
number to me is right now they're losing
70 million dollars a day yeah I mean 70
million dollars a day is nuts
probably gonna come back but you know
what AAA did American Airlines
pay for life you know what they did they
extended all of the elite statuses for
another year so if your elite status was
gonna s January 2021 they extended to
January 22 hey for life this was a
humble brag but it wasn't very humble
because he just wanted to tell you that
he's weak oh yeah listen I only fly
American I'm like whatever they want to
do I'm in this they're amazing it's just
telling me that I got other [ __ ] to do
you know that you're not the most
important thing going on I'm gonna get
in trouble for that later what's going
on with the NCAA boy I learned that that
is the college edition the college
edition yeah it's the college governing
body for sports college edition oh they
say you know wise n-c-double-a cuz
they're to a got a genius on my hands I
just I just did why'd you laugh the
n-c-double-a top so oh it's not that
they support a proposal to allow college
athletes to sign endorsement contracts
and receive payments for other work so
the NC double-a forever has hidden
behind this sham remember I said the
virus is exposing all the shams the
biggest sham the NCAA ever did was they
said you're an amateur athlete you can't
get paid any money for anything yeah but
they just you're not allowed to get paid
for anything so what that meant was you
can't have a big social audience and
then a business come to you and say hey
can you tweet about my business I'll pay
you for great so that's not a lot you
also couldn't do things like put my face
and name on a product and then sell it
I'm using my image and likeness but the
whole argument was wait a second how can
you say that when for example the
n-c-double-a store was selling my Jersey
it's my Jersey right and when you search
in the NCAA store at one point you could
search like Anthony Pantheon oh and then
my Jersey would come up and they with an
instable a would make money but I would
get none of it so they're using my image
and likeness how come I don't get paid
from it so right well because you're so
yeah um I went to the University of
Georgia we had this college athlete I
guess on the football team who got in
trouble I think for signing yep not
anxious now I can't get paid to do it
okay if you sign then selling yeah you
signing it and sell it then you would
get in trouble so a whole idea is this
is why it's a sham is because the
n-c-double-a makes hundreds of millions
of dollars off these athletes and they
don't pay them and people always say oh
no we get nothing zero so people always
say oh when they get a scholarship right
oh okay but do they actually get the
real education that the rest of the
students get probably not too they most
of these kids would qualify for like 80
to 90 percent of other types of eight
right when I went to school they'd get
aid to you for all these different
purposes and the scholarship is just
another piece of it so it's all a sham
well it just didn't I'm just joking but
like the Sham is that they're not paying
athletes because here's the other pieces
they imagine all the health concerns
right so like let's say I played
football for three or four years right
and I get two concussions and then I
have health issues moving forward I get
nothing right or let's say that I'm a
big-time athlete right and I'm actually
making my school millions of dollars and
also I blow my knee out I never make it
to the NFL or the NBA I don't get paid
any money they made all this money off
me and I'm just kind of thrown to the
wayside so how is this gonna affect
future you know students who want to go
to a college for football are they gonna
like become millionaires and college
like what's gonna happen here well
there's two things right so one is
there's a lot of people who are trying
to attack the NCAA and basically create
alternative paths like the NBA now came
out with this new program that's like
hey don't go to the NCAA and play
college basketball for a year before you
can go to the NFL or NBA Draft
instead go to this like kind of testing
oh sorry
is it football no it's every school okay
yeah it'd gotten governs all sports so
the other thing that you're talking
about is basically yeah they're gonna
make a ton of money right the the really
really best athletes but still like the
guy who's you know not playing a lot or
not popular they're not gonna make
anything or the girl who doesn't you
know play a lot they're not gonna make
anything either and so the whole thing
comes down to now you're gonna get into
issues we're like what happens when you
hand an 18 19 year old kid who's the
star athlete a million bucks well
they're gonna do crazy stuff right and
that's always been one of the concerns
but still that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't allow them to make a living
Wow right alright so tick-tock
what why is this in here what is going
on you're obsessed with tick-tock I've
been are you addicted no no I'm trying
not to be then hit you with a Carol
Baskin that's one of the dances so
tick-tock across two billion downloads
after the best quarter for any app ever
how many people downloaded it in q1 more
than 315 million installs that's nuts
that is nuts to put that in perspective
Facebook has 2 million users like tick
tock has just as many installs
approximately as Facebook no it's Warren
thing no it's not but there's not 315
million is a massive number yeah that's
probably bigger than any yeah that's
right bigger than any quarter I ever saw
when I was at Facebook it's very crazy
because I think now people it's
attracting not just teenagers but also
their older sisters or their moms or
whatever and it's really crazy and to
see like all the mom content on tick
tock and they're like 25 and you're like
oh my god they're 25 and have like that
ten-year-old okay maybe not maybe
they're 28
yeah it's called demographic expansion
so a lot of times what happens is a lot
of mobile apps or like to have social
component to it they penetrate a single
demographic so I'll say high schools or
colleges and then what they do is well
two things happen so one is you're the
demographic that first downloaded it
starts to get older so just naturally
they keep using the application if I
download it when I was 20 and now I'm 25
I'm still using it naturally gets older
second is it takes time for those social
circles to kind of expand out so one of
the key things that most social apps
know that a lot of people don't realize
is there's massive explosion around
Thanksgiving and Christmas because what
happens is in a college a bunch of kids
are all using something they go home
they tell their friends from home right
so you get cross-pollination across
schools and also now I'm hang on my
older brother my younger sister my
parents whatever and you get all this
growth you remember when so I have a
little sister who's in high school gym
ago and I made a tick-tock with her we
are not going to talk about that that
was a crime literally that was a
criminal activity the video you sent me
I thought that that was going to let
somebody die oh speaking of that home so
do we think much got bodied does that
mean when I tackle you know it means
when you show up with your guns hanging
out on camera then all sudden start
daddy and me in the comments so so do we
think that now because all these moms
and like older siblings are on this app
it's gonna get less cool just like
Facebook did no it's good
I think it'll continue great mine
because the whole thing around Facebook
was like the parents came in to like spy
on their kids instead I think what's
happening here is like the parents are
participating but they're actually in
the videos right there create they're
doing dances like all right what's going
on with the couch put a tree it touch
petite reott Burger King Hunter Hayes
campaign this is not an ad but um Burger
King's basically like do your part for
America stay on your couch and so what
are they doing they created a yeah
they're donating was hard to read the
article when you bought one that's
behind a paywall you come every go the
headlines oh she got hit with the
paywall
bang bang paywalls personally I'm long
McDonald's short Burger King Burger
King's fine but I'm actually a bigger
McDonald's fans everybody hit me you see
this you see this life I live gotta be
kind of dodging
my head on a swivel we stay ready so you
gotta get ready you know saying but no
so it's pretty cool that Berger keeps
trying to get people to stay at home on
their contract if you guys see we just
jump out of my chair it's yeah you got
violence going on here but McDonald's is
definitely better than burger I mean
like that's just like a known fact um
have you ever had a whopper
yeah do you think it's better than
becoming the golden state would you
choose McDonald's or chick-fil-a would
you choose McDonald's or Bojangles
really oh yeah man no geniuses okay so
what happened he didn't eat meat for
like six months in the way he broke me
streak was by having like a massive
Buddha Bojangles and had the four piece
chicken supreme dinner or whatever it is
and then I ate it three times in two
days I was ready to roll I was like
welcome back to the meat world it was
great all right anything else what else
you have here um oh so okay
so you might have noticed that I didn't
do anything crazy for the subscribers
today because someone rained on my
parade
somebody told me hold on technically
somebody said that if you didn't bring a
pistol into the episode that they were
gonna unsubscribe and then you showed up
with your guns just trying to keep us
our subscribers okay would you do this
for some no I'm out all right guys I'm
out already will you do the next video
shirtless maybe alright what's next
will you that was bait for all the men
watching up the balance beam I didn't
take the bait I just completely sidestep
that [ __ ] and just kept pushing all
the guys go ahead will you wear a white
t-shirt no I don't own any that's true I
do own one with my dogs baseline maybe
I'll wear that one one would you do
Marine Corps push-ups Marine Corps
push-ups are too easy they're the light
push-ups they're like super easy
push-ups so like I do arm
boy she looks a little bit harder all
the marine guys will understand what can
I understand what it what is it
I'm joking what is the difference marine
the Marines the army the Navy they all
just have like basically I don't know if
it's appropriate to say this but they
just have like a pissing contest and so
they all do push-ups different ways
not really but they just say that so
here's a tip if you ever have to say I
don't know if this is appropriate
don't say it this is the difference
between you and I when you think that
you don't say it when I think that I say
it would you no I would not do that that
sounds ridiculous well you love to see
people you know what the hat and
sunglasses in the next video
polina's beautiful whatever she wants to
wear it's fine with me look what okay
you alright look times up no more
questions
guys that's it for lunch money today
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us trying to get our lunch money
right again please smash the like button
that's what we keep getting told smash
the like button leave a comment I try to
respond to all of them share the URL
basically do all this crazy stuff to
make this stuff go viral so plain old
e-famous she can't wait or alternatively
just click the like button gently and go
on with your day that's it for today
we'll see you guys like there